[Musique]
donc parlant de la conférence en tant qu
trail dans les contextes cette pandémie
l'a7 contexte virtuel comment vous les
vivez vous les organisateurs voulaient
participer à cet événement ben je vous
remercie pour la question c'est une
bonne question parce que c'est
évidemment comme pour moult d'événements
un événement qui devait avoir lieu en
présence y est donc qui demandait quand
même montage relativement important on a
plus de 1500 participants
donc on a on a usé de de capacité
d'adaptation et d'imagination et je dois
dire que j'ai très hâte d'assister à la
première qui se déroulera en other
aujourd'hui ce mercredi 20 mai puisque
je pense que l'équipe d'organisation
réussie autour de m plusieurs dizaines
d'ateliers de cours de séances plénières
et tout cela en direct je supportais pas
une bonne capacité technologique
oui je comprends que ça doit être toute
une organisation autour de cette
nouvelle façon de faire les choses
donc cette conférence réunit autant des
invités du secteur privé comme déjà du
monde universitaire aussi du
gouvernement et de la société civile
mais dit ça et comment didier au début
ça analyse un peu l'avancement du canada
dans ses objectifs du développement
durable est ce que vous diriez que le
canada fait bonne figure
ou encore il y a beaucoup à faire au
niveau de ses objectifs la peinture il
ya ces objectifs-là donc au nombre de 17
avec un peu près cent soixante dix
cibles précises sont très diversifiés de
la lutte à la pauvreté jusqu'à
l'inclusion en passant par l'accès à une
eau de qualité je pense qu'il ya des
domaines dans lequel le canada le canada
affiche des progrès relativement
important je pense entre autres aux
dialogues qu'on a réussi à entamer
même si ce fut difficile mais ce fut
très difficile mais qu'on a quand même
réussi à entamer je parle dans une
perspective relativement positive avec
avec les peuples autochtones
puis se rappeler on peut se rappeler ce
qui est survenu quelques quelques
semaines à peine avant l'éclosion de la
pandémie dont je pense qu à plusieurs
égards le pays est quand même sur une
voie qui je pense qu'on se veut engagé
énormément
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de travail à
faire mais on se veut engagé
je pense que c'est je pense est
prometteur je pense
faut il faut s'y intéresser en même
temps il y à la présence du canada à
l'internât l'intérieur du pays comme dit
auprès des peuples autochtones entre
autres mais il est aussi la présence du
canada à l'étranger
l'étude des aspects particuliers qui
préoccupe les gens qu'ils vont
participer à cette hausse organisateurs
du sort de cet événement là qui
préoccupe en ce qui concerne la fête du
canada à l'étranger
oui parce que les piles le principal
c'est là je dirais que c'est la colonne
vertébrale si vous me prêtez
l'expression de la conférence et klein
shing les changements climatiques à ce
niveau là c'est sûr que la lutte contre
les changements climatiques condé c'est
nous à l'université de de présenter
comme une action climatique qui se veut
plus engagés c'est un défi qui est à la
fois locale donc local national mais
également internationale et à ce niveau
là c'est sûr le canada entre autres par
ce qu'on appelle sa transition
énergétique qui doit qui doit qui doit
absolument se poursuivre de façon
décidée à absolument rôle à jouer à
l'échelle internationale oui et puis on
a vu dans les derniers jours qu'il y a
eu des importantes avancement à ce
niveau à ce qui est ce qui concerne par
exemple la quantité des gaz à effet de
serre qui sont dans l'air en ce moment
pendant celle des pandémies par les gens
sont à la maison et qui sorte d'utiliser
moins leur auto est ce qu'il y aurait
des justement des leçons à tirer à ce
qui concerne notre travail notre façon
des failles et nous engage ment ou le
changement climatique qui pourrait de
cette pandémie
oui non seulement il ya des leçons à
intégrer mais et ça c'est notre c'est
notre pari c'est notre c'est notre
devoir nous qui sommes des chercheurs en
environnement il faut absolument
il faut absolument qu'on puisse répondre
à cette pandémie en attirant l'attention
justement sur ce qu'on appelle urgence
climatique
donc là il ya des choses effectivement
vous l'avez mentionné ya par rapport à
la même période l'an dernier à l'échelle
internationale un article qui vient de
paraître
hier je pense sur cette question il ya
ya trio une diminution importante des gs
mais c'est tout c'est très spécifique
lié liées au contexte actuel il ya des
choses sur lesquelles on peut poursuivre
et puis je pense notamment à tous là
l'idée du télétravail aillent en grande
partie quand même des émissions de ges
qui sont liées à la circulation vers la
congestion routière également de façon
secondaire loyola on a des clés d'action
c'est ça n'est pas la seule mais une des
choses qu'on devra faire incessamment
c'est justement d'essayer de voir de
quelle façon on peut poursuivre sur cet
élan sur sept est là pardon mais d'une
façon d'une façon qui soit durable et
constructive parce qu'il ya des choses à
faire
au canada on peut travailler dans la
perspective la réduction des ges de gaz
à effet de serre comme je dit au début
vous êtes le directeur de l'institut
société donc et vous cet événement
ensemble quelles sont vos préoccupations
actuelles dans le contexte actuel moi
personnellement comme professeur
chercheur comme université à ma
préoccupation c'est vraiment la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
c'est l'action climatique mais dans une
perspective qui soit très inclusif et
cette perspective inclusive elle passe
aussi par un dialogue
c'est l'idée du network et sincérité du
réseau c'est exactement l'idée du to
gather de la conférence qu'on déploie
aujourd'hui donc le sait qu'on puisse
échanger sur les bonnes pratiques
d'impression créer des réseaux
de pratiques qui soit durable réseau à
l'ère virtuelle sont l'expérimentent
vient depuis depuis deux mois c'est
quelque chose qui permet de propulser
c'est un vecteur de changement je vous
dirai pour terminer là tu secondaire
mais notre préoccupation c'est tout
aussi de créer un réseau francophone
soit il faut le dire tout bien d'heure
et une conférence qui est qui créé par
l'organisme qu'on appelle sdsl
saint-herbot développe une solution
network et nous ce qu'on veut faire une
université laval
on est très active dans ce réseau la seo
participer bien sûr l ensemble des
activités du réseau mais encouragé aussi
la la création d'une branche francophone
internationale pour notamment aller
chercher les pays d'afrique d'un sdsm
donc ça c'est sûr mais préoccupation est
celle de l'institut eds et y verte
professeur agrégé au département de
géographie de l'institut hydro québec en
environnement développement et société
de l'université laval
merci vous pouvez avoir accepté cette
entrevue pour être canada international
aux premières merci infiniment par le
massif il manque les haies
[Musique]